schärfere gesetze gegen missbrauch der
bundestag gibt ermittlern mehr rechte
bei der verfolgung von kinderschändern
im internet dicke luft bei den bauern
sie protestieren gegen strengere
umweltauflagen und fordern mehr
anerkennung handballer im aufwind nach
dem überzeugenden sieg gegen
weissrussland richte sich der blick auf
gegner kroatien
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und den abend willkommen
bei heute 19 uhr mit norbert lehmann der
in knapp 15 minuten den sportbahnen
jetzt ein stimmwunder amt auch von mir
kinder sind im netz gefahren ausgesetzt
von denen eltern oft nichts an
bei online spielen oder im chat gruppen
tauschen sie sich mit vermeintlich
gleichaltrigen aus hinter denen sich
aber nicht selten straftäter verbergen
die sich so den kindern sexuell nähern
cyber grooming nennt man das diese täter
aber auch solche die bilder von
kindesmissbrauch verbreiten sollen nun
leichter überführt werden können der
bundestag hat dafür heute die weichen
gestellt
sarah attacke täter sprechen kinder über
das internet an versuchen eine beziehung
aufzubauen
das ziel sie wollen nacktbilder sexuelle
handlungen vor der webcam oder die
kinder treffen um sie dann zu
missbrauchen
dafür können pädophile schon jetzt
bestraft werden leoni ist gerade mal
zwölf jahre alt als ihr das passiert ein
fremder mann kontaktiert die schülerin
über ein forum
nach dem kind komplimente und verspricht
ihr geschenke wie damit umgehen das ist
für kinder und jugendliche wie leoni im
anonymen internet oft schwerer zu
entscheiden als im persönlichen kontakt
wenn irgendjemand sagt kommen zu mir ins
auto ich nämlich mit sagst du nein zu
reißen was weg und das wurde sehr oft
und sehr offen auch kommuniziert aber im
internet gibt es diese ganz klaren
grenzen die sind nicht wirklich die sind
viel schwammiger orientiert es ist nicht
ganz klar oder für mich war es und wenn
es nicht sehr klar wo es dann wirklich
gefährlich wird diese grenze zu ziehen
ist für kinder so schwierig weil die
täter sehr geschickt vorgehen erst
erschleichen sich langsam das vertrauen
des kindes geben sich als gleichaltriger
freund mit gemeinsamen interessen und
täuschen verständnis vor bevor sie dann
langsam erste gefälligkeiten verlangen
diese pädophile zu überführen ist für
ermittler wie staatsanwältin julia bus
weiter sehr schwierig denn wenn
verdeckte ermittler wie sie sich als
kind ausgeben um pädophile zu überführen
konnten diese bislang nicht bestraft
werden erst seit heute durch die
gesetzesänderung wird diese strafbarkeit
lücke geschlossen die intention des
täters dass er nämlich auf ein
minderjähriges kind
ein wirbt die ist die gleiche egal ob
auf der anderen seite tatsächlich ein
kind oder ein verdeckt ermittelnder
polizeibeamter so sieht es seit heute
auch das gesetz eine richtige und
wichtige gesetzesänderung weil nur so
ermittler die möglichkeit haben
pädophile im internet präventiv
aufzuspüren und bestrafen zu lassen und
dadurch kinder nicht erst zu opfern
werden müssen damit täter zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden können
kinder und jugendliche wie leonie können
dadurch in zukunft besser geschützt
werden
auch die sicherheit von radfahrern war
heute thema im bundestag eine mehrheit
der abgeordneten hat sich für eine
gesetzesänderung ausgesprochen
demnach müssen autofahrer künftig mehr
abstand halten beim überholen und zwar
mindestens anderthalb meter innerorts
und mindestens zwei meter außerhalb
außerdem sollen fahrzeuge die schwerer
sind als dreieinhalb tonnen nur noch in
schrittgeschwindigkeit abbiegen dürfen
um schwere unfälle mit fahrradfahrern zu
verhindern
libyen im bürgerkrieg acht jahre dauert
er bereits an und nicht nur im land auch
außerhalb drängen viele auf frieden und
klare verhältnisse
aus verschiedenen gründen
wirtschaftliche interessen spielen eine
rolle oder die flüchtlingsfrage oder
einfluss auf die arabische welt
und so haben sich zur libyenkonferenz
übermorgen in berlin rund ein dutzend
länder angekündigt wir wären die
besonders mächtigen usa russland china
dann afrikanische länder ägypten
algerien kongo aus europa großbritannien
frankreich und italien
und außerdem die türkei und die
arabischen emirate thomas reichert über
erwartungen vor einem besonderen gipfel
um fünf uhr früh passiert heute erneut
was alltag geworden ist vor libyens
küste ein holzboot mit 39 flüchtlingen
viele minderjährig gerät in seenot alle
werden diesmal gerettet es ist wie ein
sos signal aus einem land in dem
flüchtlinge unter unmenschlichen
bedingungen leben das in kauf seines
brutalen bürgerkriegs versunken ist
er hat seine teilnahme an der
libyen-konferenz zumindest in aussicht
gestellt khalifa haftar der den größten
teil
landes kontrolliert in griechenland
verspricht er heute sich an den
waffenstillstand zu halten doch die
bundesregierung will erreichen dass auch
keine waffen mehr nach libyen geliefert
werden
wir müssen vor allen dingen dann bei der
libyen-konferenz auch sehen dass auch
das waffenembargo wieder eingehalten
wird was wir im grunde un mäßig
vereinbart ist aber leider nicht so
eingehalten wurde nicht eingehalten zb
von der türkei das den in tripolis
belagerten serra unterstützt oder von
russland dass auf seiten haft da steht
doch zumindest auf dem papier scheint
sich die um einfluss kämpfende nächte
nun einig
sie werden deshalb an der konferenz am
sonntag in berlin teilnehmen
russland war auch bei allen fünf
vorbereitenden treffen mit dabei und wir
haben uns jetzt praktisch auf die
abschlussdokument geeinigt
praktisch immerhin kein schlechtes omen
für eine große konferenz wie sie berlin
lange nicht gesehen hat und bei der sich
deutschland in einer neuen
weltpolitischen rolle versucht in
deutschland ist gewissermaßen neutrale
macht hat kontakte zu allen seiten auch
zu allen möchten dich eine rolle spielen
und wird von allen akzeptiert als
vermitteln ein ende der
waffenlieferungen das wäre ein
fortschritt für den vermittler
vor allem aber für den frieden in libyen
in teheran meldete sich beim
freitagsgebet heute der oberste führer
des landes ayatollah khamenei zu wort
zum ersten mal seit acht jahren und nach
dem abschuss der ukrainischen
passagiermaschine und den protesten in
iran war eben die aufmerksamkeit der
welt sicher bedauerte er den so wörtlich
bitteren unfall überzog aber die usa und
die europäer gleichzeitig mit massiven
vorwürfen mit wolpert vor zehntausenden
gläubigen forderte irans geistlicher
führer ayatollah chamenei in teheran das
volk auf seinen politischen kurs aktiv
zu unterstützen
den abschluss der verkehrsmaschine durch
die revolutionsgarden nannte er einen
bitteren unfall die proteste verurteilte
er scharf dahinter steckten die usa
diese clowns in amerika die lügen und
behaupten sie seien auf der seite des
iranischen volks sollen genau hinsehen
wer dieses volk ist etwa die paar
hundert die das bild unseres helden
soleimani beleidigen oder die millionen
die bei der trauerfeier dabei war tut
den usa keine kompromisse skandierte die
menge
präsident salih hatte am mittwoch noch
einen politikwandel gefordert eine
zusammenarbeit mit anderen staaten haben
dagegen nannte großbritannien frankreich
und deutschland wegen ihrer haltung im
atomstreit heute handlanger amerikas
denen man nicht trauen könne der
präsident verließ das gebiet sichtlich
verärgert die botschaft des obersten
führers zum widerstand gegen amerika kam
bei den anhängern an
wir alle sind traurig über die opfer des
flugzeugabsturzes das sind auch märtyrer
aber die verantwortlichen dafür sind
doch amerika israel und ihre handlanger
viele terraner die nicht am gebiet
teilnahmen sehen sich dagegen in ihrer
ablehnung des regimes bestärkt seit 2009
werden wir von dieser führung ihr
systematisch betrogen und belogen
schlimmer geht's die innenpolitischen
spannungen sind mit der rede haben es
heute wohl noch nicht beendet
zurück nach deutschland und da gibt es
heute einen rekordwert
noch nie haben bei uns so viele menschen
gelebt wie im moment
ende 2009 10 waren es 83 2 millionen
allerdings wachsen wir langsamer als in
den vorjahren um 200.000 im vergangenen
jahr dass wir mehr werden liegt
ausschließlich an der zuwanderung mit
blick auf den arbeitsmarkt sei die auch
dringend nötig meinen die
bevölkerungsforscher des statistischen
bundesamtes asylbewerber andersdenkende
und polizisten angreifen das war laut
staatsanwaltschaft ziel der sogenannten
freien kameradschaft dresden fünf männer
und eine frau wurden heute am dresdner
landgericht verurteilt zu haftstrafen
bis zu sechs jahren
sie seien teil der kriminellen
vereinigung gewesen und hätten sich an
attacken gegen ausländer beteiligt etwa
im sommer 2015 im sächsischen heidenau
die neonazi gruppe soll mehr als 40
mitglieder gezählt haben
klima und umweltschutz die meisten
menschen dürften dafür sein was jedoch
darunter zu verstehen ist wird je nach
sichtweise unterschiedlich beantwortet
von freddys for future bewegten anders
als von landwirten die sich nicht in die
giftspritze ecke drängen lassen wollen
ob bio oder konventionell heute
verschafften sich beide gruppen gehört
und wer wollte konnte auch zwischentöne
vernehmen wie moldau und fabian köhler
berichten zwei großdemos zwei politisch
eher geteilte lager die einen kommen mit
dem fahrrad die anderen mit dem traktor
nach hannover beiden bewegung geht es um
1 ihre zukunft die landwirte wehren sich
gegen aus ihrer sicht zu scharfen
umweltauflagen fordert mehr respekt und
faire preise für ihre produkte
wir landwirte sind aus der gesellschaft
ein bisschen an den rand gerückt was
natürlich auch verständlich ist weil wir
auf dem land leben und die gesellschaft
lebt größtenteils auf dem start auf der
stadt und hat keine keinen bezug mehr
die canon supermarkt und im regal ist
alles rund 1700 traktoren die innenstadt
nahezu lahmgelegt und nur einige hundert
meter weiter die klima- aktivisten der
protestbewegung fridays for future
lautstark halten auch sie den druck auf
die politik aufrecht liegen inhaltlich
mit den landwirten gar nicht immer so
weit auseinander
in unserem kampf für klimagerechtigkeit
ist soziale gerechtigkeit auch ein
besonders wichtiges thema und das heißt
dass auch landwirt in die dringend
notwendige klimaschutzmaßnahmen auch
erfüllen müssen dann aber auch die
soziale unterstützung brauchen um das zu
können und dementsprechend gehen wir
auch gemeinsam mit landwirten auf die
straße dieses auch zu sehen
immer wieder härtere vorschriften die
umwelt zu schützen treibt die landwirte
auf die straßen
doch viele hier sagen auch für sie ist
die umwelt lebens und arbeitsgrundlage
denke ganz einfach dass wir beide auch
freitags fünf user ja für umweltschutz
sind und deswegen sind wir auch hier wir
sind für umweltschutz für insektenschutz
für grundwasserschutz und nicht dagegen
glaube das ist gar nicht so viel trennt
verlangen von der politik genauso wie
wir rahmenbedingungen dafür weiter
existieren können landwirte und
klimaaktivisten zwei bewegungen die
mobil machen perspektiven für eine
lebenswerte zukunft fordern nicht nur
kein fleisch sondern auch der verzicht
auf eier und milchprodukte immer mehr
menschen in deutschland ernähren sich
wegen 1,3 millionen sollen es
schätzungsweise seien viele weitere
bauen als sogenannte flexitarier
regelmäßig veganer oder vegetarische
produkte in ihren speiseplan 1
fürs klima für das tierwohl oder die
eigene gesundheit immer größer wird die
auswahl an solchen produkten die man
inzwischen in quasi jedem supermarkt
bekommt diesen trend spüren auch die
besucher der grünen woche in berlin der
größten ernährungsmesse der welt
elisabeth schmidt angrillen auf der
grünen woche
sie sehen aus wie bratwürste sollen auch
so schmecken bestehen aber aus pflanzen
eiweiß vegan und vegetarisch liegen im
trend vor ein paar jahren waren die
produkte noch absolute exoten
mittlerweile liegen sie fast in jedem
kühlregal
der deutsche marktführer aus dem
niedersächsischen bad zwischenahn
verkauft mittlerweile 40 prozent seiner
produkte als fleischlose alternativen
wir nutzen derzeit klar
haben uns aber auf die fahnen
geschrieben dass wir alle produkte wegen
herstellen werden vegan ganz ohne
tierische produkte dieser markt wächst
rasant fast alle großen traditionellen
fleisch hersteller orientieren sich um
wenn man einmal die ganz konventionellen
fleischprodukte sieht dann fällt einem
auf dass man in diesem markt kaum noch
etwas verdienen kann auf der anderen
seite habe ich fleisch ersatzprodukte
und in diesem bereich sind die menschen
durchaus bereit für das gute gewissen
sehr viel mehr geld zu bezahlen
so kosten bei rügen weil der frikadellen
ohne fleisch 30 prozent mehr micah
schlägt bei seiner vegetarischen
currywurst die hälfte drauf gutfried bei
seiner wette fleischwurst sogar 90%
viele verbraucher vor allem junge leute
greifen trotzdem zu tatsächlich weil ich
mir vorgenommen bei weniger fleisch zu
essen aber weniger aus also einfach nur
aus moralischen gründen tatsächlich
gerade in zeiten des klimawandels sollte
man ja auf fleisch verzichten oder ein
bisschen weniger essen
ernährungswissenschaftler raten trotzdem
bei den fleisch alternativen auf die
inhaltsstoffe zu achten weil nämlich die
produkte oftmals sehr viele zusatzstoffe
enthalten die sind technologisch
erforderlich als aus gründen von
geschmack aussehen immerhin nicht nur
auf der grünen woche versprechen viele
hersteller ihre produkte weiter zu
verbessern
und jetzt zu einem kunst krimi mit gutem
ende vor 40 jahren haben diebe fünf
wertvolle gemälde aus dem schlossmuseum
in gotha gestohlen die bilder waren
verschollen darunter werke von frans
hals oder jan lievens im vergangenen
jahr tauchten die gemälde plötzlich
wieder auf und wurden anonym zum kauf
angeboten
einer der spektakulärsten kunstraub in
der ddr ist damit zwar nicht aufgeklärt
doch wenigstens sind die bilder wieder
da sie wurden heute präsentiert nils
schneider
da sind sie fünf meisterwerke aus dem
sechzehnten und 17 jahrhundert mehrere
millionen wert
ich denke mal es ist aber für die stadt
gut ein besonderer tag weil heute etwas
zurückkommen was wir seit vielen jahren
vermissen was etwas vom trauma von gotha
wieder auflöst noch immer ist unklar wer
hinter dem diebstahl auf schloss
friedenstein steckt und wie die bilder
die damalige ddr
lassen konnten 2018 wurden die gemälde
anonym der stadt gotha für viel geld zum
kauf angeboten
zum schein ging man darauf ein es ist
aber kein geld geflossen
da die zwischenzeitlichen besitzer immer
wussten dass es diebesgut war hatten sie
keinen anspruch
im rathgen forschungslabor berlin wurden
die gemälde untersucht und fazit ja es
sind die echten mit hilfe von uv
strahlen oder alten und neuen
röntgenbildern konnten die
wissenschaftler das bestätigen nun steht
die restaurierung an vorher werden die
menschen in gotha noch gelegenheit
bekommen die gemälde zu sehen
sie werden einige tage im herzoglichen
museum gezeigt und nun zur hand bei em
und zu dir norbert klasse auftritt der
deutschen mannschaft ja und vor allem
durch diesen souveränen sieg gegen
russland sind selbstvertrauen und
zuversicht zurückgekehrt genau zur
richtigen zeit denn schon morgen abend
geht es ja gegen einen ganz schweren
gegner kroatien die gute stimmung im
deutschen team ist zurück lockeres
aufwärmen nach dem überzeugenden
auftritt gestern in wien noch zeit zum
durchatmen bleibt nicht der fokus liegt
schon voll auf dem nächsten härtetest
gegen kroatien mit einer hohen
intensität die vorteil herforder lich
ist werden wir richtig gut spielen
können
ich glaube viele zuschauer können sie
auch noch an vor einem jahr dieses duell
in köln erinnern das sagt alles aus wie
intensiv es da zur sache ging und das
erwarte ich auch morgen bei der heim wm
gewann das team von christian prokop
noch knapp mit einem tor vorsprung
morgen dann das vorentscheidende spiel
dieser hauptrunde bei einer niederlage
wären die deutschen so gut wie
ausgeschieden
bei einem sieg wieder voll drin im kampf
um das halbfinale
vorhin natürlich russland gesagt
weißrussland war es natürlich das spiel
zu sehen bei uns morgen abend ab 20.15
und gleich 20 15 im zdf
bundesliga-rückrundenauftakt schalke
gegen gladbach noch ein dreier in
gelsenkirchen was erwartet uns in der
hand na hoffentlich ein spitzenspiel in
diesem spitzenspiel schalke der fünfte
empfängt der gladbach den zweiten
treffen zwei überraschungsteams der
hinrunde aufeinander und die frage wird
natürlich sein wer von beiden kann
gleich oben dranbleiben und weiter im
meisterrennen mitmischen
der mann über den in dieser winterpause
am meisten gesprochen wurde alex niebel
ist übrigens nicht dabei ist nach wie
vor gesperrt nach seinem kung fu tritt
sie erinnern sich und kann heute nicht
mitmischen aber es wird trotzdem
interessant sein zu sehen ob es
reaktionen aus der schalker fankurve
gibt auf seine entscheidung den verein
zu verlassen und zu den bayern zu gehen
vor allem freuen wir uns aber auch guten
fußball zum start dieser rückrunde
da gehören zum wintersport die deutsche
biathlon damen staffel hatten nur knapp
den ersten podestplatz in dieser saison
verpasst beim weltcup in ruhpolding
führte das team zeitweise sogar dann
aber leistete sich vanessa hinaus stehen
fünf fehlschüsse und damit zwei staffeln
die fehlerfreie schlussläuferin die
nächste herrn denise herrmann konnte den
rückstand wieder verkürzen aber für mehr
als platz vier hinter norwegen
frankreich und der schweiz reicht lösen
am morgen ist die herrenstaffel dann ab
10 und 40 wintersportort im zdf
bleibt noch das wetter da kommt von
westen her regen auch etwas schnee und
heute nacht roth glätte alle
informationen zum wochen entweder gleich
von katja honnefer so viel von uns danke
ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit christian
sievers erwartet sie mit dem
heute-journal in der halbzeitpause des
fußballspiels also schon um 21 uhr 15
und wir sind morgen wieder hier punkt 7
schön start ins wochenende
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute kam tief
heike heran und im westen gab es bereits
den ersten regen das ist eine kaltfront
wieder heran kommt und damit kommt auch
wieder schnee in unsere reichweite heute
nacht nicht nur in den höchsten lagen
der mittelgebirge sondern durchaus auch
weiter unten es kann auch ganz
gefährlicher eisregen dabei sein zum
beispiel im erzgebirge im oberfeld und
dem bayerischen wald wie auch auf der
schwäbischen alb da kann es also
tückisch glatt werden passen sie da
bitte auf die temperaturen sinken in
dieser nacht auf 6 grad an der nordsee
und bis minus ein grad in niederbayern
und steigen morgen über tag auf zwei
grad an den alpen und bis 8 grad zb der
uckermark morgen vormittag fällt etwas
schnee oder regen hier im südosten sonst
beginnt der tag meist trüb mit wenig
sonne an der nordsee gibt es schon die
ersten schauer und die weiten sich am
nachmittag aus da können durchaus auch
graupelschauer dabei sein hier in den
mittelgebirgen oder auch im schwarzwald
der wind dazu wehte büchern kommt aus
westlichen richtungen
und auch am sonntag gibt es noch einige
schneefälle vor allen dingen an den
alpen und schnee und graupelschauer auch
noch in den mittelgebirgen in der neuen
woche aber gibt es dann dank des wuchs
eckhard viel mehr sonnenschein es wird
wieder ruhiger schönen abend und ein
schönes wochenende